il ya ding vous vous êtes je disais vous
présente à l'heure vous êtes chinois
vous êtes toujours dire de nationalité
chinoise et alors vous connaissez très
bien en chine la langue française tout
ce que vous avez traduit du français en
chinois des auteurs comme sartre comme
baudelaire comme malraux je crois enfin
bref et puis me connaissait très bien le
français et vous êtes arrivé en france
je crois là à la faveur d'un concours de
meilleur traducteur c'est ça oui c'est
ça en quelle année c'était en 85 80 donc
il ya très peu d'années vont être un peu
tanné csssae alors bon mais vous deviez
rester combien de temps en france bat
depuis je suis resté je suis retourné
une fois mais depuis je suis resté jeu
je reste jusqu'à présent oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi avez vous décidé de
rester en france
enfin je ne décide pas des cités n'est
pas le mot je ne décide pas jeter si de
rien peut-être moi j'ai laissé constance
qui décide je laisse ces sites et les
circonstances c'est tout aussi comme
j'apprends que j'ai commencé à apprendre
le français c'est pas du tout mon choix
c'est plutôt sur le français qui m'a
choisi c'est enfin vous voulez dire que
vous n'avez pas de volonté si j'ai une
volonté mais c'est pas moi qui ai choisi
le français
tout commence par a ajourné je crois
d'hiver de 1976 quelque chose comme ça
et puis je travaillais dans un village
tout comme tous les jeunes qui ont été
envoyés à la campagne comme après les
étudier au lycée que je travaille
j'étais en train de creuser des canal
puis j'étais plaindre pour partout sur
puis un garçon est venu map lundi le
secrétaire du parti
tu fais là je vous la demande est alors
je suis revenu je croyais que j'étais
j'avais très peur je croyais pourquoi il
m'a dit ça y est ça fait trois ans que
vous êtes là on juger on a réuni les
paysans outre on croyait que vous avez
bien et des répliques et paf on vous
envoie à l'université pour apprendre le
français
je lui ai dit mais qu'est ce que c'est
que le français une mouture française se
sont toutes la langue qu'on part en
france
et je sais je suis parti à apprendre le
français comme ça on tout de suite ça
m'a plu et que est il une après je suis
retourné je suis retourné dans le
village ils m'intimidaient être l'enfant
c'est qu'est ce que c'est bon je parlais
pour jour répond soir des phrases très
simple que j'avais pris pendant la
première année il maintiendra ou êtes
vous contente
vous savez on a hésité quand même entre
les études aeronautica et le français je
sais pas si moi je me demande que je
choisis un choix excellent je ne sais
pas si c'est l'erreur ou pas est-ce que
vous avez eu un choc culturel quand vous
êtes arrivé à paris le choc n'est pas
venu tout de suite
évidemment comme tout le monde c'était
très différent l'achitecture et en
écrémant évidemment j'étais prêt à tout
à tout accepter en plus il traduit des
livres mais le choc est venu nous ronger
jeudi rouget parce que c'est touche
souvent dans la nuit lorsque j'étais
seul lorsque j'essaie souvent lorsque je
rencontre des problèmes les difficultés
niamey dans la journée jamais le losc il
fait beau et jamais lorsque genre je
suis en face de quelqu'un c'est souvent
lorsque je suis seul c'est quelque chose
qui qui monte en haut je ne peux pas
accepter ça en face le choc ça vient
très lentement mais je crois que
maintenant le choc devient de plus en
plus fort c'est pas au début au début
s'il n'y a pas de choc ne sais pas le
mot choc mais là vous avez donc écrit
deux livres en langue française
directement et donc la halle inquiet
quand je disais que j'étais obligé
encore obligés d'utiliser la première
fois je dis qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire pour vivre en france et
ça s'est produit en question première
jour deuxièmement je je suis là je
voulais
rester un peu plus longtemps que prévu
il faut que je gagne ma vie alors à ce
moment-là j'ai cherché un peu je me suis
dit qu'est ce que je vais faire et du
coup on est comme j'avais écrit en chine
j'avais écrit en chinois
et puis maintenant je me suis dit
puisque j'avais appris le français il
faut que j'améliore ma langue française
et deuxièmement puisque j'ai des choses
à dire que je ne pouvais partir en chine
alors à ce moment là je vais dire en
français écrit en français en face c'est
ainsi constante 7e tout comme sage
arrange
et puis ça a marché tant mieux et au
fond vous allez rester en france tant
que vous y serez heureux donc vous
pourrez voilà c'est justement c'est ça
c'est à dire je ne décide de rien ce
peut-être à jour tout va s'écrouler puis
j'ai plus de choix je le gère a obligé
de faire autre chose mais donc je crois
en tes sites est peut-être celle tamo
justement dans cette civilisation dans
la civilisation occidentale est un
disque chez nous on décide jamais rien
enfin on laisse voir les circonstances
ont fait avec les circonstances je crois
que c'est ça ils sont quand même qu'il
vaut aux illustres compatriotes qui un
jour a quand même décidé par exemple il
s'appelle mao tsé toung quand même il a
décidé quand même certaines choses
allaient peut-être la conversion sera
très longue
je n'étais pas d'accord